can you hear me now
hello yes okay it works now
hello
i need to
the light's a little bad here
hello hello hello
i have watched episodes one through four
already i'm just gonna watch them all
with you now
hello
um is chris gonna screen stream uh i
don't know
it is alley cat slash alex's
birthday
uh
i'm not actually sure k-pop yes andrew
k-pop
hmm is chris online
why are my thumbnail loud well that's
rude
that's really weird why didn't my
thumbnail load
huh
my internet's been kind of spotty
so
oops
so i guess that's why dang okay hey
enchantrex how's it going hey sue hello
hi
mr anderson what's up marcus what's
going on
uh yeah i don't i don't know um
if chris is doing it
chris's internet has also been acting up
lately
giving him a text right now
are
you
streaming
scent
hello new zealand
bunch of people from a bunch of
different places love it
what's up everybody
yeah i'm excited to hear what people
think of this show i think it's very
clever
i do
from
hello back
uh i am in la yes i am that's why the
the background and everything is
different i'm here in my my la la place
yeah she-hulk uh
episode one should be out where's my
time right here and probably about seven
minutes now
and you know what last time i tried to
do it from this pc let's take a look
here
it actually
didn't let me
stream at the same time
while watching
disney plays it like showed the black
screen
they're getting really good with the
technology to like keep people from
recording it
to to the point where it's like i can't
even
i can't even stream while watching it at
the same time not even like stream it
but just stream while watching it at the
same time
which is getting pretty
excessive but like i totally get it
i get it
they don't want people
recording it
putting it out on the internet
let's see if it'll well that's the
trailer well let me even watch the
trailer
oh
maybe
no it's just
it's just a black screen dang it all
right i'm gonna have to watch it on my
phone
but i've already seen it twice actually
so i'm not too upset about that i'm
really curious just to hear what you all
think about it
uh chris is not asleep he is texting me
but his internet is acting up
i i know how he feels because my
internet is kind of acting up right now
too but we're alive looks like we're
streaming all right just fine
if you use naver whale i've never heard
of that
i've heard of naver in the k-pop
community
but yeah
oh thank you all
for your kind words uh this episode's
like
they're all like everyone i've seen so
far is like 30 something minutes like 32
33 minutes um
not incredibly
not incredibly
long
but i think like with the pacing of like
how the shows are it actually works
really well like i think like loki
episodes worked well like being longer
but
since the show's a lot faster because
loki was like a little slower this shows
like really
a lot faster i think the shorter times
kind of work because it doesn't actually
feel that short for some reason i guess
because i like enjoyed
watching it maybe
maybe that's why
yeah enchantrex it's always fun when a
new marvel show comes out i'm excited to
see where the show's gonna go i'm not
going to say too much i don't want to
spoil anything at all
and i i always i really like when people
form their own opinions
that's why it's like when i do my
reactions my reviews i'm always so
hesitant on like what exactly
to say
because i don't want to really
influence people's opinions too much
i don't want to say hey this show is
really bad i didn't like it and that
might make people not like it despite
the fact that they might actually like
it if that makes sense like if i say hey
i don't like this
it might make somebody not like it
regardless whereas if i don't say
anything they might go into it they
might like it you never really know
i actually i was watching
i was oh i was i was watching a youtuber
review like the best
k-pop songs of like 2021 or something
like that
and i
they were speaking badly of like some
songs i really loved and so it actually
made me
like re-listen to the songs and like
listen to what they said and i kind of
like stop myself and go like you know
what no i love this song i've always
loved these songs
and i'm not gonna like let the opinion
of someone else make me like try to
re-evaluate whether i like it or not i
like the songs like i love them and i
think it should be that way with movies
too
so she
hulk needs to say it's morbid time i
love it hey jeff aquino oh he's coming
in with the super chats what's up jeff
uh excited for new series we're gonna
see punisher
and she-hulk oh man you know
they kind of like i think this how i
don't want to say it because i i'm not
i think it was in the trailer yes it was
in a trailer where she's like oh this
isn't one of those shows where there's
cameo each wig except this except this
except this and she's like oh but
remember who the show is really about um
so that leads me to believe maybe
um i haven't seen the punisher yet
um
i feel like that was a that that one's
more of like an out there one but maybe
not you never know i would really hope
so especially with all the news about
you know
the punisher coming back
we'll see
jon coming back
john bernthal i would love it
tahin sinha what's up we got a member in
the chat
become tom holland and spoil everything
oh i'd have to do it on accident though
not on purpose because tom holland would
do everything
on axe or at least you know he would at
least make it seem like that maybe it
wasn't all you know completely on
accident
yeah the punisher is a great show
honestly
dead up on the punisher
those are top tier shows like just like
in general hello clancy
yes because clancy is one of my best
friends we talk about k-pop non-stop so
of course that's surprising to you
[Laughter]
uh i see a few people asking about chris
his internet is acting up big time
uh
maybe he's not doesn't sound like he
actually is going to be able to go live
tonight
i hope the thing makes a cameo um
i i hope so i hope so
uh
hey wait hold on the chat's moving
really fast now
midori bushy love your videos first live
hey thanks so much for joining us here
william myers thank you for super chat
appreciate that
marbias is best move of all time spencer
i can't tell if you're being sarcastic
or not
do you think daredevil born again will
be as good as netflix oh man
um nothing interesting i oh man it's so
hard to
to tell because it's like you want to
think they are going to do such a good
job at the same time it's like that
show's so good
and um
i don't know if you caught my video
where i was talking talking about like
she hulk's going to be like introduced a
lighter punisher
i don't think the show is going to be
like that i think the show will be a
little bit darker kind of like a uh
us us agent john walker bashing guys
facing with the shield hope it's like
that we'll see
uh
tahin
what's up coming in with uh member for
four months now thanks so much love to
see you punisher but yeah in general not
as cameo i mean i shall full-fledge mcu
full-fledged show in the mcu yeah i mean
i would
i would love that i would love that love
it love that
hello ramen sub for three years oh man
thanks so much
thanks thanks so much
that's a long time it's a long time to
stick with me i appreciate it
uh it's out warren okay thank you mr
anderson i have to watch this on my
phone
uh
because disney plus is stopping me from
watching on my computer because i'm
streaming at the same time if i was at
my
home not in la
this would not be an issue
oh wait why why is it always logging me
out of stuff i've never asked you to log
me out of disney plus on my phone
mr anderson if you could start a timer
please because i can't do it on this
computer setup here
but we are going to start
she-hulk uh if i can ever get my
password right
oh you know what i can do though
oh i think i know
here let's do this okay we're about to
start
what the heck is it
if we do this
if we do this
okay if everybody's ready to start this
we can about start it
if mr anderson is ready to go with the
timer
oh sorry the chat's lagging a little bit
yeah yeah all right
we're gonna get going we're gonna get
going we're gonna start it
in three
two
one
boom
let me see if y'all can hear that
i don't think y'all can hear
that but let me know in the chat if you
can hear the audio from my computer
because i don't want to get a copyright
and let me turn my
well we'll keep u-turn this way
okay okay okay
i'm gonna just move this two seconds
what is the responsibility of those with
power all right here we go
thank you marcus thank you all right
let's go
this guy's like such a douchebag
yep
savage gin walters look
glknh
glknh
oh i forgot to do something
hulk out
i am a hulk
and fixed
with my cousin bruce
it's actually super smart it's super
smart idea
cheetos fingers it's so smart
my theory we've all seen i think most of
us have seen this clip
the history channel
pretty busy
being a virgin
some good old diet mountain dew
the sicarian ship
oh just hearing that like cut
ah
marcus this stream is sponsored by titan
round two it's not i just don't have any
g fuel here in my la place i need to get
some sentiment
i'm sorry guys i don't have the timer i
can't uh i'm on a different pc setup
here in la
and i just can't figure out how to how
to do it
once i get all my stuff more set up here
i'll be able to do it
we are at
uh mr anderson where are we at
because i think my timing's a little off
just so you're all aware all the disney
plush shows usually come out 10 minutes
early so we're a little over five
minutes into she-hulk episode one
dustin yeah i actually know i this is
gonna sound crazy i actually like the
taste of diet mountain dew over regular
mountain dew
i actually really do
she's got green green blood
they're doing her makeup
it's morbid time
people asking where she's at i i believe
you're about to find out actually no i
don't think you find out where exactly
she is right now
that guy that asked what her name is
like what's your name he's so creepy
he's so creepy
isaiah richardson they kind of go in to
that the blood transfusion thing like
no
but yes but no it's not the origin they
do change from the comics
as you kind of just saw but bruce uh
bruce goes on to explain it in more
detail in just a bit
yes they do yogesh
girls be like
guys
liking she-hulk
what
first of all what's up malik good to see
you
i'm not sure what that means
[Laughter]
a little bit of led zeppelin action
marcus that's funny
look at that
old iron man helmet avengers theme
playing in the background
thanks lewisberry
or wait
so much it's gain thank
you leon haley hey thank you so much for
that super chat for that thumbs up
really appreciate it
all right this is kind of where he
explains this
smart hulk
mexico
tony stark
thanks gabe
except honey no i've never been to india
but i hope to one day
i gotta get to the bottom of that
what's up reeses what's going on
lethal dose
uh weirdest things yes there is a
daredevil cameo not in this episode
uh we are at about
where is it
10 20.
it is out we are watching it right now
i'm sorry i don't have a timer up today
i'm on a different computer and it's
really hard to do it right now
don't want to be a hulk who doesn't want
to be a hulk
so
well he had that device on his arm uh
the dappies
oh that's actually on
yeah thanks joe
thanks marvel and dc fan i really
appreciate that
i did too marcus i was like she i
actually thought she was gonna throw up
where she was hungry
bing bong
[Laughter]
the blade said stark on them
yes yes
what's up daniel
easy
easy huh
as far as i can tell
cool
i say that she hulk is hot i'll go ahead
and say it
no shame no shame
that bruce did really say i think he
said bruv not even like bruh
maybe it was bro
first avengers film
oh
i don't have a great explanation for it
i love it
i love how he calls the hulk the other
guy
the hair kind of confuses me she's
definitely hot
but the hair confuses me
bruh
it was a monster
that never goes away
teach me how to hulk teach me teach me
how to hope
uh scott you asking me like when this
takes place in the mcu
because it takes
i don't know the exact date
once you get some rest we'll change
tactics in the morning
this putting metal on all the furniture
yeah it's definitely after
the snap obviously yeah that means after
end game it's probably like a
year a couple years maybe a year after
end game
because remember the post-credits scene
of shanghai bruce was still in bruce
form and now he's back to smart hulk so
it's probably maybe like a year after
laughter end game
what's up bimbo what's going on we're
about
about 18 minutes into the first episode
yes leon after ragnarok
just trying to show how it's done he
throws a boulder into out of the
atmosphere
a more billion bucks that's funny
completely
uh this kind of gets
makes me a tiny bit emotional this thing
so
so
bbts bruce banner tony stark
a good time during a hard time
so that was during the blip the five
year gap
put it in the binder
i'm not bored i've just seen it twice
already
he's like getting very aggravated let's
just focus on each day that comes
what else you gonna do as a hulk i love
it
um
uh
is
i love how like
confused he gets
and like she could control it and he
can't
so
he's i would be pissed about the hulk
too be like dude i had to fight with
myself
for years
he is
he is quite in a comic book
the cgi on the hulk is actually really
good
it's very it's actually very detailed
it's not so detailed on her but on
smart hulk it actually is
say a bunch of meat things like that to
take off
you think that hurt the hulk come on
that right joe
that's a sucker punch
i love how he holds her like that
yeah louis yeah
the hulk cj looks crazy good
hers could be amped up a bit i love it
oh
i love it oh it's so cool
that's all you got
boom
coconuts to the face
i mean you can kind of tell that bruce
is taking it easy on her
surfboards
she broke his glasses
not cool
two hulks yelling at each other is
pretty cool
right and it's pretty cool to watch two
hulks yelling at each other
no
the bar
[Music]
see right there it kind of seemed like
the hulk heard her breaking the fourth
wall
so
that still doubles down on the thing
you're apologizing for
poor hulk just once friend
foreshadowing
has no crazy hulk stuff yet
foreshadowing
hmm
no the dappies no
yes in front of everybody
i love her i love her yes yes hurry up
do it like hurry up
[Music]
that punch definitely looks like it's
super hurt
i also find this part funny because like
titania is super strong oh watch the
post credits everybody watch post
credits i love it it's hilarious
yeah watch watch the be sure to watch
the post credits scene because i i find
it one i find it pretty funny
it's not too long after like you don't
have to wait till like the very very end
captain america
steve rogers is not a virgin
hahahaha
i want y'all to watch the post-credits
scene because i find it
super hilarious
uh no that was not the feminism i was
talking about and to be fair i don't
actually think it's that much of a
feministic show i think it's a
reality-based show i was more talking
about like i heard other people
uh once i got out of the the launch
event i heard some other people say that
and i've seen people say it online and
yadda yadda i i think it's just a
reality and to be honest
yeah i think the first uh
i i
i'm not saying the other episodes are
bad by any means whatsoever but i think
the first episode is my favorite maybe
the fourth episode's my favorite that
i've seen so far i don't know this
episode was just good to me right i mean
uh
i don't know
this is just a good episode to me and
like
when i when i said it's a fun
series i think a lot of people are like
oh that means it totally sucks i was
like no it's it's it's fun like
it's it's fun
hey what's up jake woof
yeah yeah see enchantrex yeah like i get
that like that's what i'm talking about
when it's like
in
realism that's what i said like the
stuff about being a woman is relatable
to you because you're a woman and like
that's what i mean some people call that
feminism i call it reality it is what it
is people are going to say dumb things
people are going to say nice things
that's what i kind of meant by like some
people are going to hate it some people
are gonna love it and i like like i said
i'm here for the ride i uh
i like it
um
i like it
excuse me
so what do we what do we think did uh
did uh did y'all watch the post-credits
scene yeah i really might be one of my
favorite post-credits scenes uh
yeah
yeah
nine out of ten okay marcus okay
enchantrex nine out of ten as well ten
out of ten all right we're getting some
ratings what does everybody think
i actually am i am i wrong thinking that
the hulk
had better cgi than she hulk i felt like
like
bruce banner's fate mark ruffalo's face
was like super detailed anybody else see
that it's like they didn't really detail
tatiana's face that much
but like you could tell like bruce
benner martin ruffler hey
i'm getting
okay okay
okay getting some 10 some nines we're
getting some lower ones like some fives
and some sixes okay
psychotic fly right was not post credit
great i really liked it
do
and the color yeah she does seem
greener
she hulk seems like greener than
[Music]
huh
old look did better than in game yes
yeah there was a lot more texture on the
hulk's face mr anderson that's what i'm
getting at is like it looked really
detailed
that's true hunter makes a good point
they've had years to work on mark and
not and really not any time to work on
she-hulk
i have to sneeze
excuse me
oh
oh
and i'm not even saying like this cgi is
bad i'm just saying like hulk seems
super detailed
cozy the dawn i like your response it
was a calm seven i liked that i liked it
yeah 10 out of 10 post credit for sure
uh jd i don't know if it's that i'm used
to him i i do really think he was really
detailed on his face and she does she
didn't have like like that much detail
i'm not saying like it was horrible like
the cgi is bad it wasn't the first
trailer that we saw but this is so much
better than that
but he i think he looked more detailed
leon thanks for super chat
cartoonish more not a
not a real color you're talking about
she-hulk
i would agree might agree
see
what is it i think the chat's moving so
fast i was looking at a comment i can't
thank you liam for saying bless you
uh where did it go
um i lost it i'm sorry
whoever you were i'm sorry there was a
question and i wanted to answer it
j.a wasn't the post credit scene great
yeah
oh ronnie trash so is it confirmed steve
rogers is dead uh i don't think so i
think maybe like the general population
thinks he is dead maybe
um
i don't know
uh without spoiling it are there more
cameos coming
i mean yes and if and if you've seen the
trailers you've seen other cameos
um
keep in mind there are nine episodes
i've only seen four
you know so i don't know what's up i
don't know like everything
that's going to happen
so
doggo 10 out of 10 she-hulk versus hulk
fight was sensational entertainment
loved it
then me marvel oh miss marvel
yeah i like this show more than miss
marvel and i i said that in my review
today
uh
demigod
underscore teal thanks for that super
chat so she-hulk comes first before miss
marvel mcu timeline
uh we don't have an exact
like pinpoint of when this takes place
in the timeline but i'm
gonna guess this is probably like a year
after end game because if you think
about the shanxi post credit scene
uh when we saw the hologram it was bruce
banner with his arm still hurt and so
clearly that was before this because he
healed his arm in this first episode so
i'm gonna say it's like a year after in
game
yeah i think this was one of the more
stronger first episodes of the disney
plus marvel shows
yeah lewis berry better pilot exactly
yeah
who would win in a fight she hulk rwanda
wanda i mean
i i think you could almost say anyone's
name first wanda and wanda wins you know
yeah yeah yeah uh chen uh the casting
for shield is brilliant like i said in
my review today i think all the cast
members in this nail their roles i
really do
all right even like the douchebag guy
lawyer
he's the actor's doing his job to make
you not like him and think he's like a
douchebag you know what i mean so he's
do i think the cast just nails it
and jameel i
i like her i
i think she's very attractive we're
talking about thinking she hulk's
attractive that tani i think is very
attractive
yeah joe yeah it's it's i think it's a
really good
i i think it was a really good pilot
i think it was a a good first episode
probably one of the best
from marvel that we've seen on disney
plus really
yeah
marcus yeah
i mean magic it's like magic versus pure
strength right it's like magic's you
know gonna win i mean
look what she did to the illuminati
right i mean
yeah leon they they don't they don't
ever just do like a direct adaptation of
the comics and i don't think they ever
really will
hey hunter that's good yeah i you know i
didn't uh
i didn't know what to think going into
this
and um
you know i stayed true to what i said in
my review
the episodes i've seen so far don't top
one division or loki for me um
moon night but it's still a really good
show like and
i would i can argue that
this start it this starts off better
than one division did like the first
episode
first episode for loko is pretty dang
good to me
and i just recently uh
watched them again recently i just
recently re-watched them again that's
what i meant to say
and uh man i love loki such a great show
such a great show
uh garrison yeah the post credit was
really good and most of the post credits
are gags like that
um just so you all know because i think
there's a post credit every time
but anything i've seen so far just don't
get your hopes up that like
that are like something really really
really big is coming up uh it hasn't
been teased in a post credit yet there
are some teasers that come in future
episodes though
what's my favorite disney plush shot
thor uh loki
loved loki i loved everything about loki
everything about loki i even loved like
what episode four or five that everybody
calls like the filler episode i loved it
love knows four i
yeah i loku is my favorite one ovations
my second favorite uh
moon knight my third
yeah
no i really liked one division
yeah they they do i i i'm really glad
there's post credits too and i'm
actually kind of glad that they're like
fun and funny that's like
today when i said in my review and i
said the show is different
and refreshing it's it's like what this
is exactly what it is it's a very
different show and i feel like it's
lighter like it's it's a light-hearted
like comedic show
and i don't know it's just that's how i
feel
and i'm like it's very enjoyable and
it's very fun
right whereas loki to me was like super
intense and i'm like wow what is going
to happen like i want to know where this
going is it kang what's going on with
the timekeepers it was like super
intense right and they had comedic
moments inside of it but there was
really really serious moments as well
whereas this is just like so
lighthearted and fun it's just like
really enjoyable to watch
um yeah
so a lot of people are asking about the
sakara spaceship
they kind of going to address it that's
all i'm going to say
briefly barely like they don't really
they don't go into any detail at all but
it's not the last time it's mentioned
yeah
yeah i never said the [ __ ] was bad
i definitely like it better than hawkeye
i like it better than miss marvel it
probably so far sits as my fourth
favorite disney plush show
but we aren't done
it still could
overtake moon knight potentially for me
but i don't know i really like midnight
i don't foresee it overtaking loki at
all i don't foresee it overtaking one
division for me but maybe midnight it
depends on how it ends
just
that is what the hulk moved before yeah
and that's and i think that was a
pretty blatant setup of a hulk movie
like talking about this uh zakarian ship
where he's like was probably trying to
send a message to me i'll have to check
that out later i'm like
yeah in your own movie right like
right
hey thank you that guy xd
yeah yeah yeah
who was the chick who broke in the
courtroom that was titania
how about falcon and winter soldiers sue
uh
i think that
it wasn't a super
memorable
show for me there were some really good
really good moments of the falcon in the
winter soldier
but that probably sits
ah
i don't know if i like hawkeye or miss
marvel more
that's a hard one
i might i think i like miss marvel more
than hawkeye and i think falcon in the
winter soldier probably sits right above
hawkeye
maybe
yeah
so uh i mean th this for some of you
talking about like uh
uh she-hulk right we'll get uh
uh
back in the she-hulk uh
they
the pacing
that was an origin story right i mean
really like we started off with like a
tiny bit of lawyer talk and she's like
okay hold on we have to talk about me
being a hulk thing and it was the origin
story and i thought it was really good
um
i don't know if i would have liked to
have seen the blood transfusion play out
a little bit more
it's like in the comics she's shot um
you know guy
hires assassins to kill her bruce
spinner takes the hospital
he's like she needs a blood transfusion
he like decides right
and
this is like his blood drips like into
her blood i'm not a doctor i don't know
how it works right
i don't know and i don't know the
science behind gamma radiation you know
what i mean so i don't really know how
that all works um
could have been played out a little bit
more sure but keep in mind that's really
quick episodes and i think i'm all right
with seeing more of like the interaction
between her and the hulk and him and his
lab and all stuff like that like i'm all
right we're seeing all that and i'm kind
of going pretty quickly
so yeah the cool thing about titania is
is that in the comics she gets her
powers from doctor doom
so
even you know i've been talking about
this for a while like she hulk since
they like announced that titania was
gonna be in the show i'm like whoa
doctor doom like
are they gonna make that her origin
story did
you know probably not because that would
mean or not i mean not gonna be exact
right because that would mean secret
wars would have already started
which it probably has actually so who
knows i just i hope it's doom i hope
it's doom
the secret wars like incursions and
worlds breaking would have already
started which that clearly hasn't
happened yet earth hasn't been shattered
yet so
yeah yeah
well blood got on the bottle and stanley
drank it oh i remember that madoga yeah
yeah of course yeah
yeah dunkirito i think uh
i think uh
i can't say if this episode is my
favorite yet obviously because i've only
seen four but episode one and episode
four i think were my favorite so far
episode one i think started off strong
uh leon haley fantastic four reference
what what is what was the fantastic four
reference
uh jm
jim maddie uh i don't think hulk was
really trying that hard in that fight
i think he was pretty keeping his
composure because remember what natasha
said about him he's the guy that wants
to stay out of the fight because he
knows that to win you know
yeah exactly mr anderson we don't we
don't know about gamma radiation and in
blood i i don't know how that all works
all right maybe all it takes is a few
drops of blood you know so
uh
some people are asking about the rights
to to hulk john
elite 45. uh you know there's been talks
that marvel there's been rumors for a
while that marvel marvel has gained back
those rights uh we can't really say
right now i don't really know
uh yeah and then you you know there's
some like with the rights to movies
there's so much stuff that's out there
um
and no one really knows
right because people are talking about
oh
marvel doesn't have the rights to like
those fox characters
because they're tied to the rights of
like the other actors and producers and
stuff like that so marvel can't use
x-men until 2025 well marvel has already
used
fox characters and recast them john
krazinski is mr fantastic so that like
disproved
kind of that rumor going around so you
never really know you never really know
yeah
well
you have to have the dna of like
i don't want to say a banner that might
be too general but like you know pretty
close connection to bruce and uh
jennifer
can we get a fight between
peacemaker and black adam cj super i'm
sure we could i don't think it would go
well for peacemaker even though i love
peacemaker so ritwick what's up tuhen
what's up what's going on everybody got
some members in the chat
yeah
yeah i think we are eventually going to
see a a full rage hulk i do i think
i think uh marvelous heard the fans and
i also think mark ruffalo wants
the true hulk to come back you know
i i do think we're going to get a full
ridge hulk again
yeah a lot of generic uh characteristics
uh mr anderson so it's
it's their specific genes that they have
and their cousins so yeah
morbius in post-credits scene
that's also true madoga whatever the
rock wants
the rock kits
uh
yeah no justine i totally agree i
totally agree
um i don't think it's i don't think this
show is too much i think this show is
realistic you know i think this show
talks about realistic things so
yeah i want world war hulk too um
as well not like the second one although
i would like a second one if they make
it first
uh i i would like to see the whole hulk
out again you know i think that would be
just
amazing i'd like to see a hulk first
wolverine movie i don't know if we'll
ever get that
but dang would that be cool
right
i think that'd be
cool david henry bit it the rock can't
lose in a fight i don't think so
who do i think the cameos will be tot
lamp um
i'm hoping for the thing to show up you
know we have that rumor
and anything is possible
and i think it would be kind of funny
if he showed up and tatiana said
something breaking the fourth wall like
oh hey you bet you didn't think we were
going to introduce a fantastic four this
quick or something like that i think
it'll be pretty good they'll be pretty
cool
dearest i'm glad you liked it man
yeah
ogre man yeah steve rogers thing was
pretty funny i actually like all the
references to like
um
i i like the references to
steve rogers to tony and and did you
catch like you know the whole um
uh when bruce was like our metabolisms
you know are a lot faster that's like
you know
uh captain america the first avenger
you know he's like i can't get drunk
because my cells and everything and
peggy comes in and she's just like yeah
your metabolism is like four times
you know faster
than it you know normally was so can't
get drunk
so yeah
morbius and wong
i love how maurice has become such a
meme now
i really hope he pops up in secret wars
and says it's morbid time or something
ah tahen sinha
the fourth wall break was cool what are
my views and other episodes you watch is
it good like deadpool um it's different
um i think it's used
like in a very clever way
um
i want them to be more consistent with
it in future episodes that's all i'll
say without i don't want to spoiling too
much yeah i know drizzle the iron man
helmet such a big you know such a big
one
and the avengers theme played uh as you
saw it
yeah yeah yeah
this is greg alba there's greg alba
hi greg alba
say hi to everybody oh
[Laughter]
okay what is this hi what is this have
you heard of youtube
have you ever heard of youtube before
yeah i watch uh
i watch soups okay there you go yes
so you know
[Laughter]
so you know perfectly well yes
you should get on youtube is that what
you said you should
get it wrong
what did you do why would you do that
how many people are live with you
that money damn
at this hour
[Laughter]
did i miss it where is it i don't know
not greg definitely not greg
definitely
showing respect to the mud ah thanks
leon
wait where's the one that says no we
gotta find it
this one yeah can you pin how does that
work i've never done that i ever pinned
a comment in a live stream
what is it doing i can't do it greg
sorry i can't do it greg it's not
loading me
quick were you watching the stream i did
i was hearing how you were telling
everyone that you're very sexist and
hate everything about feminism it's true
and that you thought this episode really
went hard
on the feminism and it was in your face
so much right it was like here the whole
time
it's so annoying and frustrating
yes yes
let's see
g'day greg where's the green shirt bro
i'm editing right now you're editing i'm
not editing my video for the morning and
then i was listening i'm like i'm coming
over it's great it's quicken time
it's greg time
[Laughter]
he did he screwed up my universe
i should have i should have been wearing
your uh
your your red daredevil beanie please
where's chris
uh his internet apparently screwed up
what a great excuse to
lazy yeah hey greg you're getting too
close man get away
wait what is this
wait where'd it go i thought it's greg
alberta
i'm sitting down
that's it's almost equivalent i'm short
i guess you guys didn't know
i'm like five
eight i don't know bring back chris
that's what everyone wants release the
greg cut
i'll cut greg's hair and sleep that one
uh yo so this is kind of crazy
he's got he's got to get greg the hell
out
wait what am i messing up your flow on
the stream i thought you were about to
end that's why i was i am about to end
i'm gonna have to do some work before it
ended
you know what before it ended this this
is a good time to end because i actually
have to get to work greg reminded me
because he is working right now
i hope people can hear you he's going to
be writing tweets about how
how so freaking woke this was in his
face all the wokeness warren has on the
nose each time
one of these days someone's going to
take you seriously
try to cancel me this isn't
such a freaking anti-feminist
clarified no i'm not
your audio sounds good
where did you buy your beanie people
want to know uh oh i have no i bought i
don't know i think about off amazon
amazon people you heard it here i got
the scoop for you
spencer jensen says hi greg
and sword says no one out pizza's the
hut i thought that was important i think
your stream would be better if i was
just
like back here
just like in the
i don't think we're gonna see you i
think there's a glare
if you let bugs into my point oh there
it is
wait hold on hold on
hold on
[Laughter]
this is what happens when you
when you live
behind greg in his guest house
greg you're a scroll
just letting you know
they told me
it's somewhere up there
bye hi roy justine trevor this is the
crossover we wanted we live streamed
yesterday together i know
greg leave him alone
i can't i can't leave
so greg had a
a bench like in the backyard which is
just right here um and just so you know
like how do i describe this so like
there's greg's house like the yard and
then my little place here
and uh so like the backyard's the same
and uh greg used to have this bench
like right outside of his window
and then he took it away one day i was
like that's where i used to sit and
watch you guys through the window into
your room why'd you move it now i have
to stand and watch you guys in your room
oh yeah show them me and greg went to
arcade today and look what greg got me
because he's the best date ever
it changes colors can you tell
and now it's pink
and now it's green
stop it light and now it's
blue purple
my favorite color
it's the best thing ever
protect it with your life
i've answered all the [ __ ] questions
i didn't have my door unlocked he
knocked and i unlocked and i just
reached over like this and i unlocked it
all right but it is time where were you
going you got to say woof all right
not yet hold on i'm saying
200 viewers since i showed up i want you
to know that i gotta say 200 viewers
since i should have must be your face
it's got a it's got to be your face
it's probably because you're not one of
the people who are not you're not
wearing a red beanie yeah yeah
so all right guys well uh we're i'm
going to wrap it up or say we this is
greg's streams now i'll do the stream
for you buddy yeah um but i gotta get to
work so thank you mr anderson for again
being the best mod you are awesome uh
it's woof woof time it's greg
you're mephisto i would love to be
mephisto then i'd take out eric voss
at least it would finally be confirmed
as you were killing him and he'd be like
the best way to go he'd be like i knew
it
and he'd die in peace
but all right everybody we will see you
next time thank you to everybody who
stopped by thank you to everybody for
the super chats for the regular chats
and if you're just watching just
chilling listening like greg does
secretly in the background thank you as
well
hopefully the majority of you won't show
up to my house
at one in the morning like greg did but
thank you
no no no no i'm not trying to kiss you
i'm trying to say
woof
woof okay hold on jeff likes k-pop i
gotta answer that thank you for the
watch party once again looking forward
to your uh react video pink venom on
your other channel yes i am going to do
that uh that's tomorrow
no
what's the day oh we should start and
only fans oh okay you want feet picked
uh yeah only feet only only is that of
only feet yeah only feets only feet i
don't cut my toenails and uh i feel like
i could be a very niche can you like
hands department go up the tree like a
bear
with your toenails like is that what
they do yeah
they use their feet
yeah oh that's cool that's how bears
climb trees oh i didn't know that
educate yourself never studied the bear
before okay anyways yes i'm gonna i hope
to do a reaction my other channel back
back to the the goodbyes we have to work
i love you all
i used to say i love you all three
thousand but now i say i love you all in
every universe because i like that one
better you gotta say let's go
let's go
sochi gomez
she's my best friend i love greg
[Laughter]
tell them goodbye greg
woof people
follow get warren to a million share his
videos
oh wait i'm looking at here
yeah all right guys we'll catch you next
time